Yeah,
what I be sleep,
try to do this,
understand human nature,
how the mind works,
what makes us tick,
what are the patterns of thought and
emotion and motivation that characterize
our species.
I focus on language partly because you
can't make a living out of studying
human nature.
It's just too big a topic.
You've got to pick something tractable
to study.
For me it is has been language in a deed
for much of my career,
one little corner of language,
namely a regular and irregular verbs and
I have my reasons for focusing on that
particular corner.
I think it does shed light on larger
questions about what makes the,
the mind work.
Uh,
but language is a general topic is a,
I think a good entree into human nature
for a number of reasons.
It's distinctively human if you're
interested in general in what makes
humans,
unlike a mice and birds language is a
pretty good place to start.
Not only because of language itself,
the fact that we make noise with our
mouths in order to get ideas across,
but because language has to be fine
tuned for the kind of thoughts and the
kind of social relationships that humans
want to share and negotiate with one
another.
So it's a,
it's a window into human nature.
It's also figured in debates on human
nature,
perhaps most famously with Chomsky in
the late fifties,
using language as a way to rehabilitate
the idea of innate mental structure.
Something that was virtually taboo in
the 19 fifties.
He said language is a very good
candidate for something that is innately
and uniquely human.
So it's an opening wedge for the idea
that,
uh,
that important parts of the mind are
innately structured.
It's also a,
a prime case of mental computation.
It's very hard to make sense of language
of our ability to string words into new
combinations.
Sentences that other people have never
heard before,
but can very quickly understand for the
first time without appealing to the idea
that we have a,
a mental algorithm,
a set of rules or a recipe or a formula
that picks words out of a memory store
and strings them together in
combinations where the order as well as
the choice of words is meaningful.
So language sheds light on the idea that
the mind is a computational system.
I did what I think is the,
isn't for a long time will be the most
exhaustive study of one aspect of child
language development.
The fact that kids make errors like,
uh,
I,
oh,
we holding the baby rabbits,
the alligator gold kerplunk where they
add a regular suffolk's like ed to an
irregular verb,
like a hold or here,
or stick producing errors like stick to
tared and hold,
uh,
I analyzed 20,000 of those forms from
computer transcripts of children
developing language and developed a
theory of why kids make that error,
uh,
how they outgrow it and what it shows
about language.
The reason to obsess over a tiny little
topic like that is that it's a nice
illustration of children's creativity in
acquiring language that the essence of
language is that you aren't restricted
to a fixed list of messages that you've
memorized and that you then regurgitate
like a parrot.
Rather you're,
you recreate me combined elements to
create new messages.
Every sentence that we utter is a brand
new sentence,
but it's rather hard to study the
process of,
of kids making up new sentences when a
kid says something like strict or tiered
or hear it or hold it.
That's a tiny example of recombination
that I think is the engine that powers
language as a whole.
The,
uh,
the,
the act of children making an error like
that I think is a way of catching them
in the act of doing something that makes
language powerful.
Namely combining things by rules.
And in trying to understand that one
phenomenon,
I hope that we,
my students and I shed light on the
process of linguistic generativity or
creativity in general.
Um,
I also
tried very hard to crack the code of
what verbs mean and how that influences
how we use them in sentences.
The verb is in a way the chassis of the
sentence,
once you pick the verb,
it's got slots that the rest of the
sentence a is built around the subject,
the object,
the indirect object,
prepositional objects and so on.
So knowing how the verb works tells you
a lot about how the sentence works and
how the verb works depends on what the
verb means.
You might think,
how could you ever get your,
uh,
get a handle on something as nebulous as
what a verb means.
But,
um,
but I like to think that,
that I,
I cracked a lot of that code.
What's the difference between a verb,
like to fill in a verb,
like to pour and a verb,
like to load.
They're not just a video images in the
head of someone pouring and filling and
loading,
but rather they have an anatomy.
They built out a parts parts,
like two cars to move a means versus end
a let versus four versus cost.